we may finally know how accused killer
Brian coburger is connected to his
alleged victims a law enforcement Source
tells People magazine coburger reach out
to at least one of the victims on
Instagram coburger is accused of
stabbing four University of Idaho
students to death in their off-campus
home in November an investigator told
People magazine just two weeks before
the murders an Instagram account
believed to be co-burger's message one
of the girls repeatedly but did not get
a reply Lasorda says they were mostly
messages saying hey how are you but he
sent them over and over again it's
possible the victim didn't even see the
DM request since Instagram sends them to
a separate folder than regular messages
coburger's Instagram account has now
been deleted but People magazine says
prior to that happening it appeared
coburger was following all three female
victims Kayla Gonzalez Maddie Mogan and
Zana konogle all lived in the home on
Kings Road zana's boyfriend Ethan Chapin
was the there the night of the murders
and he was also killed
Terry with the discovery of these
Instagram DMS or direct messages do you
think the prosecution could finally have
a motive and what do you think it could
be well you know what Brian as we all
know you don't have to have a motive you
just have to show the intent to kill for
murder and we have that I think with all
of the evidence but the motive here I
think might be multiple the fact that he
might have been rejected in his own mind
by one of the victims and we've heard
reports that he may have also been
rejected by other women that he
approached in bars so he very well could
just be angry against women and the fact
that he's being rejected constantly the
other issue is we know he has a master's
degree in criminology he was working
towards PhD maybe he just wanted to
commit a crime and see if he could get
away with it he thinks he's smarter than
everyone else so I would combine that if
I were the prosecution in this case and
go after both those motives yeah
rejection a little bit of Catch Me If
You Can Jesse if this is all true why
wasn't it mentioned in the probable
cause after David I think it could be
one of two reasons one it's a probable
cause affidavit you don't need to
include everything in there this is not
all the evidence to support a conviction
against Brian Coburg or just what was
the evidence to support him being
arrested they might have still been
developing information and I think the
second reason could have been they just
didn't know about it remember this is an
ongoing investigation we are going to be
learning a lot more about Coburg or
police are and prosecutors are between
now and an eventual trial they're going
to talk with more witnesses they're
going to learn more about them this is
the start of the investigation so don't
be surprised if there's going to be more
that comes out that wasn't in that
problem because affidavit yeah I can't
wait for that preliminary hearing uh
we'll probably get even more in that as
well well thank you both authorities in
California say a gunman stood over a
teenage mother and her 10 month old baby
and shot them both in the head deputies
in central California are trying to
figure out who carried out a Brazen and
brutal attack this week killing six
members of the same family that death
toll includes not only the baby but also
a grandmother who was shot while she
slept the sheriff had initially said
this was a cartel shooting but has now
been walking that back saying they're
still looking into it however he said
the home where this happened is known to
law enforcement for gang activity three
people survived the shooting including a
man who called 9-1-1 as he hid inside
the home the teenager and her child were
not so lucky
she was found along with the infant
laying next to her mother his mother
down the street
we believe that the 16 year old teenage
mother in her small infant actually was
fleeing and running from the scene
what we have since learned through
forensics that it was clear that the
shooters stood over the top of the 16
year old mother
I fired rounds into her head
the 10 month old infant also suffered
from the same attack
none of this was by accident
Tara simply the authorities are playing
all the stops and putting in every
resource they can what do we know so far
about this well you heard the sheriff
they're talking about how horrific this
crime was and because it was so
outrageous they do have local state and
federal agencies and he said that and I
don't want to get this wrong so I'm
going to take a look the crime lab is
out there on the scene forensics gang
detectives homicide detectives the
California Department of Corrections is
on the scene and he mentioned also that
Federal league on the scene was ATF FBI
Homeland Security DEA and Department of
Justice so they are pulling out all the
stops here they're making sure that they
have every agency that they need on
every level and not only that they're
asking the people in the community for
help there's a tip line and there's a
reward so they're going to do all they
can to get these people or this
individual whomever did it and make sure
they're behind bars at some point Jesse
that's a lot of three-letter agencies
how do you think they will track down
the suspects
yeah Terry touched on a little bit I
know that they've asked local businesses
and neighbors to review their
surveillance footage from 3 A.M to 5 A.M
remember this is a small town farming
community so who would be out there at
that time akara Narrows down the list of
suspects if this is in fact gang-related
collapse authorities have confidential
informants in these gangs to find out
what exactly they know about it that ten
thousand dollar reward is currently a
ten thousand dollar reward for more
information but given the gravity of
this I wouldn't be surprised if that
number actually gets larger and more
people might come forward and also as
Terry mentioned police and authorities
were very quickly quick to process the
scene to contain the evidence and try to
get a result as quickly as possible so
that window of Escape for the suspect or
alleged suspects is definitely going to
narrow down all right well see as the
authorities narrowed down as you say
that suspect lesson if there is an
update we'll make sure to bring it to